so that's one extension of the linear
model another extension is
a
number of extensions or interactions and
non linearity
so in the in we'll talk about
interactions first
so in our previous analysis with
advertising data
we assume that the effect on sales of
increasing one advertising medium is
independent of the amount spent on the
other media
so for example in the linear model
we've got
tv radio and newspaper it says that the
average effect on sales of a one unit
increase in tv is always beta 1
regardless of the amount spent on radio
but suppose that spending money on on
radio advertising actually increases the
effectiveness of this of tv advertising
so that the slope term for tv should
increase as radio increases
so in this situation suppose we're given
a fixed budget of a hundred dollars a
hundred thousand dollars
spending half on radio and half on tv
may increase sales more than allocating
the entire mountain either tv or to
radio
so in marketing this is known as a
synergy effect and in statistics we
often refer to it as an interaction
effect
so here's a
nice pretty picture of the regression
surface
as a function of
sales as a function of tv and radio
and
we see that when the levels of either tv
or radio are low then the true sales are
lower than predicted by the linear model
but when advertising is split between
the two media then the model tends to to
underestimate sales
and you can see that by the way the
points stick out of the surface at the
two ends or below the surface in the
middle
so how do we
deal with interactions or include them
in in the model
so what we do is we put in product terms
so here we have a model
where we have a term for tv and a term
for radio
and then we put in a term that is the
product of radio and tv
so we literally multiply those two
variables together
and call it a new variable
and and put a coefficient on that
variable
okay now you can rewrite that model
slightly
as we've done in the second line over
here
and we've just collected terms slightly
differently
and the way we've written it here is
showing that
by putting in this interaction we can
interpret it as the coefficient of tv
which had been originally beta 1
is now modified as a function of radio
so as the values of radio changes
the coefficient of t
tv changes
by amount beta 3 times radio
okay so that's a nice way of
interpreting what this this interaction
is doing
and if you look at our
summary of the linear model below
indeed we see that the interaction is
significant which we might have guessed
from the from the previous picture
so in this case the interaction really
is significant
so the results in this table suggest
that interactions are important
the p-value for the interaction is
extremely low so this strong evidence
in favor of the alternative here that
beta 3 which was the coefficient for
interaction is not zero
we can always also look at the r squared
for the the model with interaction
and it's jumped up to 96.8 percent
compared to 89.7 percent
by just adding this one extra parameter
to the model
um and and we get that by adding an
interaction between tv and radio
another way of interpreting interpreting
this
is that we have a 69 percent of the
variability in sales that remains off to
fit in the additive model has been
explained by the interaction term
because we went from 89.7 to 96.8
and if we think of that in terms of the
fraction of unexplained variance that's
69 percent of the unexplained variance
the coefficient estimates in the table
suggest that an increase in tv
advertising of one thousand dollars is
associated with an increased sales
of
and we plug in the numbers
for beta1 and beta3
it's 19 plus 11 times radio units
sorry 1.1 times radio units
alternatively an increase in radio
advertising of one thousand dollars will
be associated with an increase in sales
of
so now we've written it the other way
around we've factored it the other way
around and now thinking of the the
coefficient of of radio as changing as a
function of tv
and it'll be 29 plus 1.1 times tv units
so you can make either of those
interpretations when you put an
interaction in the model
sometimes it's the case that an
interaction term is a very small p-value
but the associated main effects in this
case tv and radio do not
but when we put an interaction in we
tend to leave in the main effects and we
call this the hierarchy principle
and so there it stated if we put in an
inter interaction we put in the main
effects even if the p-values associated
with the coefficients are not
significant
so why do we do this
it's just that interactions are hard to
interpret in a model without main
effects their meaning actually changes
and and so
it's it's just generally not a good
practice
um another way of saying this is that
the interaction term also contains main
effects
um
even if you if you put the model with no
main effect terms so it just becomes
more cumbersome to interpret
now what if we want to put in
interactions between a qualitative and a
quantitative variable
turns out that's actually easier to
interpret
and and we'll see we'll see that now so
let's look at the credit card data set
again
and let's suppose we're going to predict
balance as as before
and we're going to use income which is
the quantitative variable and student
status which is qualitative and so we'll
have a dummy variable for student
which will be one if the person's a
student otherwise a zero
so without an interaction the model
looks
like
like this
and we see we've got an intercept we've
got a coefficient for income
and then we're going to have beta 2 if
the person is a student and 0 if the
person's not a student
and another way to write that is
a coefficient on income
and we've just lumped together the
intercept and the dummy variable for
student
and we can think of this by grouping
them like that we can think of this as
having a common slope in income but a
different intercept depending on whether
the person is a student or not
and if a person is a student the
intercept is beta 0 plus beta 2 and if
the person is not a student it's just
beta 0.
so that's without an interaction
with with interactions in the model it
takes the following form
um but before we study this let's just
look at a picture of these two
situations because that'll make things
clear
so in the left panel we've got no
interaction
and we see very clearly that
there's a common slope
for whether you're a student or not but
just the intercept changes
but if you put in interaction between
the slope of income and student status
you're going to get both a different
intercept and a different slope
and so that makes a really simple
explanation in this case
and if we look at the the actual model
it it looks like this so we can write it
in several different ways
um and so
this year this
this second term over here is showing us
what happens with the interaction
and so if you're a student
you get both a different
intercept that's beta 2
and you get a different slope on income
which is beta 3.
and if you're not a student there's
there's zero which means you get the
baseline
intercept and slope
and you can rewrite rearrange those
terms
in the following fashion
and and it's telling you the same thing
so
the inter the interpretation of
interactions with categorical variables
and and the associated dummy variables
actually simplifies uh is is more simple
than in in even in the quantitative case
the other
modification of the linear model is what
if we want to include non-linear effects
so here we've got the
a plot of of two of the variables in the
auto data set so we've got miles per
gallon against horsepower
and we've included three
fitted models here we've got the linear
regression model which is is the orange
curve over here and you can see it's not
quite capturing the the structure in the
data
and so in to improve on that what we've
actually done is fit
a polynomial
the two polynomial models we put a
quadratic model which is the blue curve
and you can see that better captures the
curvature in the data
than the linear model
and then we've also fitted a degree five
polynomial and that one looks rather
wiggly
so we have an ability to to fit models
of different complexity in this case
using polynomials
and these are very easy to do
so just like we created an artificial
dummy variable for categorical variables
we can make extra variables to
accommodate polynomials
so we make a variable
horsepower squared which we just include
in our in our data set and now we fit a
linear model with a coefficient
for horsepower
and a coefficient for horsepower squared
and of course that's a polynomial
expression
and we'll notice that that improves the
fit we do the summary and we see that
the coefficient of both horsepower and
horsepower squared are strongly
significant
and so you can do this you can add a
cubic term as well and in the previous
example we went all the way up to a
polynomial of degree five so that's a
very easy way of allowing for
non-linearities in a variable
and still use linear regression
we still call it a linear model because
it's actually linear in the coefficients
but as a function of the variables it's
become non-linear
but the same technology can be used to
fit such models so that expands the
scope
of linear regression enormously
okay so we've reached
we've reached the end of the session
if you read in along in the chapter
you'll see there's some topics we didn't
cover
um we didn't cover outliers
there's non-constant variance of the
error terms
high leverage points which means if
you've got
points
of observations in in x that that really
stick out far from the rest of the crowd
what effect they have on the model
and co-linearity if you have variables
that are very correlated with each other
what happens if you if you
include them in in the model so we're
not going to cover those here but they
covered um in in some detail in the book
and
if you look at section
3.33
you'll find coverage on that
okay so that finishes our coverage of of
linear models um there's a lot of
generalizations of linear model and and
and as i've hinted that already you'll
see that it's actually quite a powerful
framework
so we we use similar technology for
classification problems and that we'll
be discussing next so we'll be doing
logistic regression and support vector
machines which also have linear models
underneath the hood but expand the scope
greatly of linear models
and then we'll we'll
cover non-linearity so we'll talk about
techniques like kernel smoothing and
splines and generalized additive models
some of which are also just extensions
of linear models and some of which are
richer
a form of modelling that allow for
linearities in a more flexible way
we covered some simple interactions in
linear models here but we'll talk about
much more general techniques for dealing
with interactions in in in a much more
systematic way and so there will cover
tree based methods and then some of the
state-of-the-art techniques such as
bagging random forests and boosting and
these also capture non-linearities and
these really
bring our bag of tools up to to what we
call state of the art
and then another important class of
methods we'll discuss
use what's known as regularized fitting
and so these will include ridge
regression and lasso and these have
become very popular lately with
especially when we have
data sets where we have
very large numbers of variables so
called wide data sets and even linear
models are too rich for them and so we
need to use methods to control the
variability
and so that's all still to come and so
we have lots of nice things to look
forward to
you